what's the temperature in the bourbon
room temperature and you're seen that
smart-home is a 66 degrees Fahrenheit if
you're already you may have a smart
thermostat in your home or know someone
who does it's an example of the emerging
Internet of Things and now entire cities
are scaling up as well next month
representatives from San Diego will be
speaking at a worldwide smart cities
Expo in Barcelona I took a trip to San
Diego to find out what the future has in
store with a skyline that rises above
the bay and a border that stretches
along more than 20 miles of the Pacific
Ocean
san Diego's natural beauty is apparent
but that didn't stop the city from
giving itself a high-tech makeover it's
an electric vehicle one of the driving
forces behind the city's plans is deputy
chief operating officer David Graham we
spoke in a Fred the ride-sharing service
that's free everywhere downtown how is
San Diego changed over the last few
years well you know it's long been known
as a tourist town as a military town but
now it's a hub of innovation we are
driving past co-working spaces and
software companies some of the smartest
people in the world are coming here
three years ago facing an annual budget
deficit the city began to replace its
streetlights with LEDs Graham says the
light bulbs saved the city 2.4 million
dollars in energy costs and illuminated
a future of endless possibilities that
was really the change for us when we
realized that San Diego could be
efficient green and also save money at
the same time if we just look to the
technology providers and the smart
people in our city to help with problem
solving Graham's goal has been to make
San Diego the largest smart city network
in the US people here smart city and I
don't know if they know what that means
well for San Diego it means the use of
data and technology to improve decision
making and create better lives for
people
San Diego is in the process of
installing current by GE smart sensors
in 4200 of the city's streetlights
we've just installed one of the city IQ
nose and that is the optical auditory
and environmental sensor and in factory
sensors in each light three sensors in
one with a cellular connection just like
your cell phone so the device status is
good it's up and running it's part of
the city's climate action plan to
increase mobility and lower emissions so
what you're looking at here is one of
our adaptive traffic signal systems
Duncan Hughes is San Diego's senior
traffic engineer the adaptive signals
the smarter signals you can get they
exchange information and they change
that signal timing on a second-by-second
basis so can the traffic signals and the
streetlights work together anyways yeah
so that's kind of the long-term vision
according to max and pitcher ski the
city's chief data officer the upgraded
streetlights are able to count
pedestrians cars even monitor climate
conditions like temperature and humidity
street lights are awesome and they're
great data source right so are a bunch
of our other databases and really it's
about making something work better and
more efficient and I think that's what
being a smart city is all about how much
is technology factoring into a way to
improve urban life I think it's a huge
part of the conversation Laura bliss is
a staff writer for city lab a website
that reports on cities of the future in
2018
the smart C's industry was worth eighty
1 billion dollars so there's big money
out there and a lot of conversation
happening between public and private
smart cities can be found across the
country two years ago Columbus Ohio beat
out six other cities to win the
Department of Transportation first Smart
City challenge earning fifty million
dollars to improve mobility and
sustainability the city of Atlanta has
installed smart sensors along its North
Avenue corridor and the city is one of
93 municipalities around the country
using ShotSpotter the application allows
sensors to detect gunfire in real-time
connects to 9-1-1 and alerts police
patrol cars and Toronto is working with
sidewalk labs a sister company of Google
on an ambitious project to build a
12-acre smart city neighborhood from the
ground
up the company says the data it collects
will be used to improve public life but
last week a key adviser resigned from
the project because of concerns over how
that personal data will be protected the
promises are great you know more
efficient more affordable how happy
you're healthier lives but they haven't
really answered questions about what's
gonna happen to that data right who's
going to get to hang on to it and given
that you know this is a relative of
Google that makes its money off of our
data I think there's some really
legitimate concerns there I have to
think though that there are people out
there that think Big Brother is now
watching from those streetlights what do
you say to them yeah well think about
this that rewards card that you swipe at
a store the search that you do on the
Internet is telling people a whole lot
more about you and your preferences then
a streetlight ever couldn't would and so
we use analytics from the information to
really protect people's personal data
and information but provide the services
that we know a smart city needs and
while privacy concerns aren't going away
neither is the technology so the next
big horizon I think for us is how do we
take the underserved neighborhoods those
that have the most difficult issues
how can smart connected technology help
improve your lives because if you forget
about the people you've missed what it
is to be smart that's a really good
point yeah those are the two big things
the privacy concerns obviously but also
you have to bring this to people who are
not at the wealthiest level they're
trying to do that in Columbus with bus
service and improving that speed of
traffic but you've got to remember
everyone in all of this yeah and this
Nick Thompson Bluetooth data is
essentially power in this whole
artificial intelligence thing but it
also creates all these issues like
privacy right and people want to know is
it analytics you're just one of many or
do they know the very specifics about
you and we don't know that